hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play Skyrim okay I turned up the
brightness just a little bit because it
was getting a little dark in the videos
before but and my friends ran off ahead
of me but anyway I'm back I took my
helmet off because well I didn't like
that helmet it was ugly anyway come on
let's go ralof oh um bring it on orders
are to wait till general Tullius arrive
Oh what that sounds like a bunch of dead
guys come on sir I've totally forgotten
what sprint area nope I'm not gonna
I want a two hander not not w-willing
there we go ah no no - Henry screw you
get a bow I guess that's kind of nice
did you duck your year listen any of
these guys how about to handle available
them I have no idea
now I'm leveling up on one in one hand
is for users ah damn it
dogs so wimpy all right let's drop not
the light armor and disrupt this because
the light armor actually pretty light
and it sells for good money so that's
why I want to give that and the officers
humming through that yeah
mmm let's go on ahead see if the way is
clear good job good job there buckaroo
chunk chunk there we go I've forgotten
how long be interesting cuz was like all
of it even this tutorial beginning part
if that's what you want to call it
hi dragon I'll just step up Boeing boy
yeah here we go
gimme no not that coin purse give that
and ocean feeling was it
I remember that
ooh so this Center
I don't remember this at all
Oh
oh I don't know anything about that
didn't go anywhere so no point in that
all right back to the guy over where
come on hurry up yes slowpoke let's get
going
I got dragons to kill no kidding
douchenozzle
come on spiders ooh come here yeah
miss me eat yeah yeah hi Oh where's my
big a two-hander sword oh I need to
smashed-up why do you think I made the
beefiest Argonian I could oh hello the
big nasal shoes Oh see now my oh yeah
but now my one-handed it like a little
and I don't need it's waste of levels I
don't know didn't-didn't one there a
companion with the two-hander that I saw
that I had with me and he died
apparently because he's gone now boy boy
good dog ok hold up hold up bear just
that is the bear yeah see I would shut
up you big pansy come here bear
die bare die
I'm gonna start sneaking wrong Oh
ah that's Argonian justice right there
any skeletons you lootable
no ah nothing better than the argonians
argonians are what I played in like I'll
just goes three oblivion
just everything morrowind i'm in some
here no wait where am I going
I don't know I don't know what I'm doing
that looks like the way out I knew it'd
make gonna beat you gonna beat you
oh poor Luke baby I forgot you don't use
a transport things you just go home
great looks like a yak more than a cow
just gonna say that
uh-huh come on wait wait for what
Oh a dragon not scary oh that's a pretty
Vista I forgot how pretty Skyrim is
there he goes
looks like he's gone for good this time
oh he better not come back wait to know
if anyone else made it out alive
mm-hmm this place is going to be
swarming with Imperials soon enough okay
better clear out of here
let me go back to first person my sister
Gurdurr
runs the mirror dear just up the road
I'm sure she'd help you out when they
come up with his straps we better split
up
rail off and girders have made it
without your help today oh you know you
wouldn't have all right time to go for
some extreme flower picking yes
Oh thistle yeah Oh what was that oh
nothing oh yeah I love my flowers a
butterfly rip the wave right out that
sir yeah windhelm and joined the fight
to free skyrim okay you've seen the true
face of the Empire here and I saw the
true face of a dragon
we'll know what the coming of the dress
itself why would all Frick know he's a
douche I don't know everyone's a douche
except for me come on
it's a flagging game
hey game I said come on what the hell
there we are flowers gotta be some
flowers all right where is Oh
guess I'll fall him see that ruin up
there ah bleak falls Barrow uh-huh I
never understood how my sister could
stand living in the shadow of that place
uh-huh it looks okay to me maybe you're
just a giant pansy it sounds about right
we're just stone I'm taking a shortcut
ah Wow
didn't hurt actually hurt a lot all
right what do we got thief stone
hey stone warrior stone hell yeah
straight-up beefiness screw Magican
sneaker e these are the Guardians yeah I
know what they are really there's four
mance that shut off it does shut up I'm
gonna go in this mine
I'm chime fo'got what a great mountain
climber I am because I'm an Argonian
obviously oops
hello give me that yeah look I can chop
wood can I chop wood I don't that's
close enough
what oh hello how about this is that
closer I should have come here
what about this huh I close now you're
so pretty
yeah to get your shield
if you shield me up or lady woman lady
sometimes I like being in third person
because it's more of a cinematic kills
just wait till I get my two hander you
guys are gonna get it then oh you're
gonna get it all of you up I see that
there we go okay dark dark dark dark all
right um what oh whoops
um there we go yeah let's not take away
the light from the environments already
darker it's hard to see yes hello but is
come here Jay yeah yeah no I am playing
on this on expert by the way so I didn't
have to try to be a little bit not
sucking which might be hard for me cuz
this is me you were talking about - you
okay I'm actually gonna now I is fine
it's it's a mine
Oh pickaxe or yeah
oh the terribly exciting dink dink dink
dink dink dink dink
okay that was that was so much fun right
guys right right right right everybody
yeah hello Skellington coin purse ah
never had her journal they've had me
working down here for days now it's not
the time that gets that's getting to be
though it's these tunnels I've told them
countless times add extra supports for
the weak sections of the tunnels if only
we had more of those wooden beams we
reinforce with bronze bottoms honestly
if I hear the airship one more time
above my head I'll be so stressed I may
stop drinking for good I mean what's
ignored without his Mead sorry I didn't
read that in a Nord accent looks like
that guy got totally squished I won't
read too many journals I got more stuff
to do than reading oh it's pitch black
in here search green-apple
alright fine ah spool
lever oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
shut up
want some yes
none of you have a two-handed sword
really I'm going to look up alt miss me
double smash oh what's that about a Miss
or you hit me but whatever hmm huh no
body whatever it doesn't matter I don't
need it I think I I might have a mod
that does more of those cinematic deaths
which would be really cool actually I am
gonna turn up the brightness because
this is mescaline look at this this is
something going wrong with my game I
have no idea why it does that but it is
just like oh my God why why well that
didn't help at all now whatever it's
fine it's fine
come here buddy ooh two-handed sword
gimme you're not keeping me away from
that dress I think your body's there all
right 200 sword let's just go ahead and
drop these it's going to be I've got six
of those
really
what Oh whatta hell happened I thought
my game was freezing up oh good I made a
drop I just drop all of them it's
probably a lot of weight that I need to
shed anyway drop all of them there we go
all right now
iron great sword not the great hammer I
like a great sword yesh favorite that
song
yes yeah I'll favorite the longbow to
disagrees I need it hmm yeah doesn't
this look right
doesn't this feel right chest
give me amulet of Juliana's you swear
that I'll take the wrong booze no no all
right now now I can level up with
confidence yeah yeah yeah yeah all right
um let's go health to start with safe
bet and with the extra difficulty I'm
sure it's gonna need I know argonians
are actually like meant for sneaking in
you know stinky stuff but ma that's not
me man
that's not me yes barbarian
I know what's in here can I get like a
torch or something or flashlight because
I can't see anything
there's a bucket in there get away
it you bucket right saving we want some
some see you you're mine ah yeah knock
you down Oh
see how much pwnage I dish out Oh are
you seeing all this pony genus I'll come
back and get this stuff here I just
gotta kill this guy so he doesn't rain
arrows on me I am gonna do - oh hello
don't care a whole lot that is is
I don't know
metal three arms flying through the
levels yeah that's not gonna happen bro
oh here to help walk Oh some Mead yes
please
all right now Luke rabbits here all
right what was on the table is some iron
ore like that
actually I ah smithing well thank you
all right that's actually all the time I
have for now thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you're enjoying it and I
will see you in the next part
bye bye